president biden says the u.s is standing
with the people of cuba tonight
following some of the largest
anti-government demonstrations
in decades correspondent phil keating
has reaction tonight from little havana
florida
an unheard of and unprecedented public
demonstration against the cuban
communist regime in a dozen cities
sunday on the caribbean island
bold defiance to the government's tight
grip on everything there
and exhausted with decades of poverty
and food and medicine shortages
even accusing leadership of a failed
response to coronavirus
for which the state department was
criticized after initially tweeting
that was the reason not inept communist
rule
in miami's little havana kaye ocho
filled up with hundreds if not
thousands of supporters in solidarity
with the cuban people
also calling for change as they have for
the past 50 years
with no success president biden this
afternoon
the united states stands firmly with the
people of cuba
as they assert their universal rights
and we call on the government
government cuba to refrain from violence
their attempts to silence the voice of
the people of cuba cubans on sunday also
modified the revolutionary phrase
freedom or death chanting freedom or
life
florida's cuban american senator marco
rubio posted this
on twitter of course covert has a role
to play but this began well before
covent
these people are frustrated they want to
live in a normal country they don't want
to have their kids getting on rafts and
having to leave the country
in order to lead normal lives the cuban
president miguel diaz canal
as usual blamed the island's problems on
the u.s
and its trade embargo in a national
address he accused the u.s
of manipulating emotions and feelings
through social media
u.s secretary of state lincoln says it
would be a grievous mistake for the
cuban regime to blame what is happening
there
as a result of anything the u.s has done
the hour of freedom has arrived miami's
cuban american mayor joined the chorus
for change
people are dying people are getting
beaten and people are suffering and
they're starving
and this has been happening for far too
long
[Music]
notably most left-leaning democrats have
been quiet
on the cuba issue today including new
york representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez
senator bernie sanders however did make
a short statement
he said he supports the right to protest
everywhere
and he stands by his interview he gave
last year on 60 minutes where he said
not everything in cuba is bad on the
streets of havana today
quiet no demonstrations and the internet
and social media
have largely been shut down brett you
know
phil quickly you know we know the cuban
american population down there in little
havana
intense in everything that comes out of
cuba do they feel
on the streets that this is a game
changer moment there
well some of them are now calling for
the u.s government to
intervene in the island nation this is
an opportunity
just like back in 2016 when fellow
castro died
to come gather people drive by very
slowly honking
horns all day and people banging pots
and pans and holding signs
demanding cuba change but like i said
after five decades of calling for that
nothing has happened in cuba all right
phil keating live in little havana
florida phil thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else